this morning Vice President Mike Pence
and Secretary of State Mike Pompeo are
on a mission to stop the violence in
Syria they've arrived in Turkey to ask
for a ceasefire senior foreign affairs
correspondent and Face the Nation
moderator Margaret Brennan joins us
Margaret good morning will they meet
with the Turkish president as planned
well that's the entire reason the vice
president is on the trip in the first
place to make it too hard for air21 to
say no but this entire mission is a
scramble which is put together to
mitigate the fallout from the
president's quick decision to pull out
which paved the way for that Turkish
invasion Tony what's happening on the
ground right now is that the Turks the
Russians in Iran whose forces are mixed
in with the Syrian regime are moving
faster than the US can retreat and that
led the u.s. on Wednesday to do
something extraordinary destroy its own
ammunition and vehicles rather than have
it fall into the hands of militias this
battle ground is being ceded to those
enemies so the administration and this
trip is basically about trying to limit
the extent of it that is why as I
mentioned pence is there in the first
place to try to get Turkey to limit the
damage here but at this point the Kurds
the SDF they don't really need us help
they've already cut a deal with the
Iranian back Syrian regime Russia
blessed it all of that to blow to US
influence Margaret the White House
released a letter from president from
the Turkish president air21 what did
that letter say well it was dated
October 9th and it was meant to back up
the president's claim that he clearly
warned air21 not to invade Syria if you
read it it's it sounds just like the
president wrote it it says don't be a
tough guy don't be a fool and it was
sent the very same day that the Turkish
air strikes began that shows you how
late the administration was to realize
everyone was going through with this
just three days prior
there was a far less strong White House
announcement that said the US would just
be getting out of the way and didn't
support it so these mixed messages have
confused even air21 who said he can't
keep track of President Trump's tweets
Margaret thank you